[Music]
the start of the new school year in
Ukraine or anywhere else is usually
filled with Pomp and Circumstance
in fact September 1st is celebrated as
the day of knowledge in Ukraine this
year though as the war there rages on
getting ready for school means setting
up bomb shelters in the few schools that
are still standing and instead of
Traditional School supplies it means
sending students with emergency kits in
case of a Russian missile strike Deborah
patter reports
[Music]
there are many ways to spend one's
childhood in Ukraine turning spent
weapons of war into boyish Games should
never be one of them
nor should go into school for the very
first time like little Sofia be
tarnished by fear her mother Susana has
packed two bags one for class and one
for emergencies schools cannot open
across the country unless they have bomb
shelters like this one the school has
tried to make this space as child
friendly and inviting as possible with
toys and bean bags and puzzles but it is
still an underground bunker and children
will only come here when it's too
dangerous to be outside
Sophia and her new classmates are given
a celebratory welcome taking turns in a
beloved peacetime ritual ringing the
school bell
but it's also a day etched in sadness
Sophia's father bless is on the front
line do you miss your daddy yes
I'm sorry he's not here today
without warning the tears well up
it is only the start of Sophia's
academic life but already she's
discovered things no child should ever
have to learn
so many schools have been destroyed
often deliberately targeted by Vladimir
Putin's Rockets
Vera narrowly escaped having to study a
new Kremlin curriculum where in her
hometown of isium was liberated after
nearly six months of Russian occupation
the Ukraine Army very best
she is anything but a Carefree 16 year
old
I've been so sad this whole time I just
wanted everything to be as it was before
the war she said and I was so very
scared
there is none of the typical teen
rebellion and Scorn for adult Authority
do you think you've changed
I've become more responsible I obey
rules she told us I no longer want to
waste my life I want to do something
meaningful
foreign
that was in Russia's firing line for
more than half a year we found
eight-year-old tire and her best friend
Nastia who's six
they are the only children left in their
neighborhood after many families fled
the sound of shelling was hard to get
used to at first they said
now they barely Flinch was there more
scary for you when the bombs were going
off
I ran to the corridor straight away
it just like me loves tire and when it
happened while we were playing outside
we'd hug each other very tightly and say
how much we want this war to end
forgetting about the interview oblivious
to me Nastia leans over and Whispers
conspiratorily to her friend
by the way the war's going to end in
Winter I know it says tire
clearly repeating the reassurances of
desperate parents who have no such
certainty
Santa Claus will bring us the best
presents declares Nastia
in time for Christmas now wouldn't that
be something worth hoping for
there are many ways to grow up in
Ukraine wishing for war to end
never has one of them
for CBS Saturday morning
Deborah patter Hakeem
heartbreaking they just shouldn't you
know that's not no shouldn't have to
deal with that and and that's one that's
one uh tense place in this world there
are war-torn uh in their Strife all over
the globe and it's just why is the big
question we don't have to do it right I
I still I know why power
money and we forget about it and we're
shining a lot obviously on Ukraine right
now no no I'm focused but you're right
there are other countries where this is
going on all I'm saying all I'm saying
is is that war there's no reason for it
right there's no reason for it